thanks for having me on i've been
watching for weeks been trying to wait
to get it live but having karate and
then class
i haven't been able to so now that i
finally have time
um
so one thing i've been
working on i've been watching you for
about
six months
uh i've read i've read all those stuff
um been watching one of the rules of
previous podcasts like that
and trying to
chase excellence and how to be patient
with it
um
would be my main thing like i've
since march i've lost around
45 pounds 46 pounds
um uh this morning i weighed 150 3.8
and how tall are you
uh five seven
okay that's a decent 22. you're starting
to turn fat in the muscle i bet
um yeah
and i've noticed that the my stomach
keeps on getting tighter so i just got
to keep doing that until it gets where i
want to be trying to aim for about 12
percent body fat okay
um
all right so uh so what's the ask here
because i mean it says here in the
private chat you're talking about uh
patient and chasing excellence what do
you mean by that
so
like i i know i'm only 22 and i have a
lot of runway left to figure things out
but i often feel like i should be a lot
farther than i am
um
in terms of like
making money and stuff like that um
i have
about a year left in my i.t degree then
i graduate um so
uh
just trying to figure out
i guess how to get ahead on that um i
only took out
two years of loans about 12 grand in
debt so i'm open what's the end goal
here like like lean into the future
three to five years and and tell me what
your life looks like in in three to five
years
uh let's see i would have a a remote job
so i can live wherever i want i'd
probably live either in west virginia or
dona nevada
to radically different places
um
i would be
in the best shape i've ever been i'd be
closer to my uh blocked in uh
karate um i wouldn't
have as much uh social anxiety
in terms of going out and approaching
women um
but you got some social anxiety still
yeah
um
uh it's more in the
trying to figure out where to go and
but once i'm actually in
uh the situation i'm pretty fine
uh i just finished um
uh joe navarro's uh what everybody is
saying
um i have it in the back shelf there
uh thanks to your recommendation so i've
been
working on uh
uh reading body language and just
learning more social skills because i've
been socially stunted
uh growing up uh always somewhat on the
outskirts of cultural groups and stuff
like that so okay so
so i mean you've come to the space
you've you've consumed some of the red
pill awareness i'm looking at my other
spokes so looks money status game frame
and captivation
i see you've got a bow and arrow set you
know on the wall over there so it looks
like you do some shooting sports you
know something along that line
um i got to ask you though dude like
what's going on with the neckbeard
um i've been trying to get it to grow in
the
in the cheeks i've been using the derma
roller recently just trying to get it to
fill in
um
i'm planning on going to the barber this
week to see how low they that they
should cut it
uh i would shave that thing off dude it
doesn't look good it like you know if
you want to have like the confidence
that you're looking for like you have to
start to develop a look um find a
find a popular icon hollywood figure
somebody that's uh
you know that's interesting that's
captivating that has a following you may
have heard at some point in your life
hey you know you look like so-and-so or
you resemble so and so go for that look
because i mean right now the look that
you're going for is you're going for
that like i t you know neck beard look
right which is you know which is fine if
you don't want to you know max out on
the other spokes in your wheel
but i i'm assuming you know that you're
here because you want to do the work and
i just got to point out the obvious
because i mean guys in the comments are
going to start to like you know
come at you on this right so you have to
start to develop a look that's going to
be compelling and interesting
you see what i'm saying like you said
you're 22.
but
in the comments right now guys you tell
him how old you think he looks right so
just
go ahead and just you know let him know
what age you think he looks but i'm
wondering from your perspective to
hear what you're saying like moff saying
here in the comments uh a neck beard is
a chick repellent it basically is
right and i'm not saying this to be you
know disparaging to you but it's like
dude what i do is i hold up a mirror and
i just point to the facts and i just say
hey you know these things are in your
blind spot you need to take a look at
them
um
i don't know if you can see the yeah
yeah so what do you say to like make it
shorter or just give it all
just shave it off like unless it fills
in up over here and you can make a nice
proper full beard don't don't roll a
beard it's like
you know the guys that like are losing
their hair and they just like grow it
out long on one side and do a comb over
or some like that it's like no dude
just stop holding on scrap shave it off
right
but i mean if you look at the comments
right now
you're 22 we got 35 we got 34 we got 30
we got 35 30 plus 35 honestly bro
29 is the youngest we got so far so
you're looking older than your age
right
you want like i'm assuming that you want
to date
women closer to your age instead of 29
or 35 year old single moms with three
kids in tow from three different fathers
i'm assuming
yeah you got to start acting as if right
like you got to look the part we got
jaren in the chat neck beard does have
to go chin strap might work but it's
still pushing it right you have to you
have to i mean if you want to rock
facial hair rock a facial hair look that
works for you if it doesn't work for you
then move on from it right like you have
to know when to take it around behind
the back of the bar and beat it with a
stick and bury it six feet under and
start over with something new one of the
things a lot of guys do when they come
at me with coaching calls you know
especially when it comes to business
stuff they're like i've got this
business up and running for two or three
years and blah blah blah and it's like
okay how much money does it make well
nothing yet
well how long have you been doing this
well you know for the last 36 weeks you
have a hobby right it's time for you to
take that piece of around behind
the back of the bar and kill it and bury
it six feet under and be done with it
it's not working once you establish it's
not working of course but right but i
mean like what i'm saying here is
you know you're looking to get some
better results and one of the most
glaring things that that
that i see that's holding you back is
you have a look that's
out of
place right
like you're not
like ugly guys don't have symmetrical
eyes one eye's higher than the other the
eyes are looking in a different
direction sort of thing right
they've got like a cleft lip or
something that misshapen you don't have
scars on you or anything like that that
i can see so like
work with what you got to hone up on it
you're already going to the gym so your
body's going to change right your body's
improving you got rid of the fat you're
toning in the belly area your shoulders
are going to broaden right you know you
can start to get some shoulders that
look good you just have to keep going
like
sorry i'm saying over here yeah
so you've got the look that the internet
memes are about right like you ever see
those memes where it's like that guy
with the neckbeard's yelling at the
other guy that looks like me with a
beard like this
this this conversation right now is
literally those two characters right
so switch over to the side
yeah so yeah switch over to a side that
makes you more attractive right that
gets you that look
um
yeah makes sense yeah i've been trying
to i wanted to fill in here because i
was
a couple of those are gonna grow it's
not gonna grow if it's not gonna grow
there then just move on from it i mean
you know try the derma roller if you
want you know like that's one thing also
when you start lifting and fighting and
all that sort of stuff like that and you
start winning competition testosterone
goes up one of the things that happens
when testosterone goes up in your body
more body hair more facial hair so maybe
it'll fill in later you know sort of
thing it may not you know maybe you're
just predisposed not to have you know
facial hair in that part of your face
don't fight it you know
move on from it okay it's like those
guys are like oh maybe five foot forward
i'm never going to be anybody and the
girls won't like me blah blah blah yeah
sure i had a roommate that was like that
height and he was a slayer right we just
call him pocket hercules he was jacked
maxed out in every other area and he did
you know like he did the best that he uh
he could right you don't have to worry
about you know asking questions like how
do you be patient when checks and
excellence and trying to differentiate
like you said over here how did how to
differentiate between realistic
assessment and limiting beliefs
start acting as if
go watch the movie boiler room there's a
really good scene in there with ben
affleck talking to the new recruits have
you ever seen it
no i have not
go get the movie boiler room rent it buy
it whatever doesn't matter it's a great
movie it's it's it's really one of those
movies that you probably watch more than
one time right but you need to like
understand the concept of acting as if
before you're going to start to execute
on it it's like when you go to the dojo
you get yourself psyched up right you
put on you know your gear you you know
you take off your shoes you get yourself
in the mindset you know there's some
warm-up activities there's some cardio
conditioning and then that's when you
start to engage in the hand-to-hand type
of work right
so you're acting as if before you even
start to fight
you see what i'm saying you need to do
that with the other areas your life so
that's why i'm using that example that's
why i tell guys to go and learn how to
fight is because that same concept can
be applied in other areas of your life
too bro
you see what i'm saying yeah makes sense
all right
come back and give me an update in like
you know a few months time and let me
know how you're making out right you
know try to establish a look you know do
all those things that i talked about
all right we'll do all right austin
thanks buddy take care
you